Sergei some people have dreamed about
photon power it sounds like a great
concept right it's a great word but then
you have to realize the practical
problems on a Star Trek they say fired
the photon torpedoes well what is a
photon torpedo a photon torpedo is a
flashlight because what is a photon a
photon is a particle of light that's all
it is
so you're basically trying to energize a
spaceship with a flashlight so now you
begin to realize the problem
it sounds really neat it sounds
science-fiction but the reality is the
practical engineering is very difficult
yes flashlights have an impulse if you
turn on a flashlight you can actually
measure the fact that the flashlight is
moving slightly because of the impulse
created by shooting out photons but it's
very small and that's the trick in order
to create for example a solar cell you
would have to have a sail that is
hundreds of miles across sailing on
photon power coming in from the Sun if
you want to have photon engines you'd
have to have gigantic lasers firing
energy from one side and how do you
energize these lasers with chemical
reactions so you're back to the same
problem chemical reactions so there is a
fundamental problem where is the energy
going to come from so photon engines
sound like a great idea
but in practice photons have very little
momentum so you have to have gigantic
solar sails gigantic laser engines in
order to propel them some people say
let's put them on the moon let's have a
battery of laser engines on the moon and
then the spaceship could be very small
it could be simply a gigantic sail you
shoot lasers from the moon to a sail and
then push that sail into outer space
well the advantage is that if the engine
is on the moon and you're simply using
this engine to push a solar sail to the
Stars then you could actually reach a
fraction of the speed of light so that's
something to look at now however I
prefer to use laser power in a different
way
what is the fundamental problem of
rocket
three the fundamental problem of the
space program is in four or four letters
it's a dirty word it is cost C OS t it
cost 10,000 dollars to put a pound of
anything into orbit that is your weight
in gold you could go to the Space
Station yes you can go into outer space
how much would it cost weigh your body
in solid gold and that's how much it
costs for you to go to the Space Station
and why is that because the rocket has
to carry its own fuel fuel is heavy
something on the order of 90% of the
weight of a rocket is rocket fuel so if
you could eliminate the rocket fuel you
could increase the efficiency of the
space program by a factor of 10 to 100
and how could you do that with lasers
what you do is you have a bank of lasers
on the earth firing at a projectile
containing water water leaks out of a
sieve and the laser beams vaporize this
water creating thrust and that shoots
the rocket into space this principle
works it's been tested as a prototype we
can already do this but there's no
vested interest there's no funding for
the laser or the microwave rocket so
again the advantage of the laser rocket
is the fact that your energy comes from
the ground that is the projectile does
not carry any fuel at all other than
water and by shooting lasers you can
vaporize the water creating steam and it
simply blasts off on steam that could
reduce the cost of space travel
enormously